leute es wird ernst
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut saß lange rum und habe mir
immer so gedacht du musst mal wieder
irgendwas machen was einfach geil ist
und was vielleicht so noch niemand
gemacht hat oder zumindest nicht genauso
wie ich es machen wir das erkläre ich
halt alles wie das geplant ist wir
machen 1000 euro paket auf und ich bin
gespannt auf eure meinung in den
kommentaren ob ihr das projekt feiert
oder vielleicht ob es eurer meinung nach
nicht so viel sinn macht aber ich finde
es eigentlich so ganz cool und es ist
realistisch und uns ist einfach so
schwer ich spreche aus erfahrung
vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine
oder andere von euch anders restposten
projekt schon letztes jahr das ist habe
ich glaube ich habe aufgehört und wir
haben auf dem konto aktuell 1100 euro
ist hier ein das geld lag ja die ganze
zeit nur ich hab da nichts mit gemacht
und ich habe mir aber überlegt irgendwie
musst du mal weitermachen und irgendwie
auch ein ziel setzen ein realistisches
ziel damit dieses ganze projekt oder
geld experiment sowie ist glaube ich
lernen werde sinn ergibt und auch geiles
und euch von folge zu folge mitzunehmen
und das ist man spaß an halt beim
zuschauen und was ich jetzt sagen wer da
klingt vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen
verrückt aber ich glaube das ist das was
da ist und ich bin vor allem mal
gespannt inwiefern ich das in meiner
rolle als youtube mit dieser gewissen
reichweite in was für einer zeit nicht
das schaffen kann okay das ist ziel von
dieser ganzen sache werde ich euch jetzt
mal ein leute vielleicht die die schon
über 18 sind können das verstehen das
erste auto ist einfach ultra nice und
ich habe es bis heute nicht vergessen
oder es ist einfach auch greifbar für
mich mittlerweile so dass man auch mal
sagen kann ohne dass es jetzt irgendwie
abgehoben über kommt oder so aber ich
habe mir das ja auch alles irgendwie
selber erarbeitet und ich finde dann
kann man sich so ein traum auch mal
ermöglichen und deswegen ist mein ziel
ein ford mustang v8 hier vielleicht mal
ein kurzer ausschnitt wo ich damals mit
19 jahren meinen ersten muster abgeholt
hat das war der kleine motor
ich würde das ist so geil ich glaub das
gern ich habe einfach ein auto
und ich habe diesen tag bis heute nicht
vergessen und deswegen will ich einfach
wieder mustang haben oder denke ich die
ganze zeit dran und dann dachte ich mir
macht es immer hier videoprojekt mal
gucken wie lange es dauert ich bin
einfach mal auf mobile.de hier könnt ihr
sehen das jetzt so viele mustangs die
alle verkauft werden ganz ganz wichtig
für mich es muss diesmal v8 seien 421 ps
ich habe mich damals auch immer geärgert
dass ich den kleinen motor genommen habe
einfach weil es ist dann kein richtiger
muss sagen es ist einfach so und das
stand ja auch super oft in meinen
kommentaren und hier gibt es wirklich
glaube ich hin und wieder mal ein geiles
angebot wo man ein muster an 40.000
kilometer also für 30.000 euro bekommt
in einem guten zustand immer ein meister
auch nach drei jahren 60.000 km drauf
und er war immer noch super in schuss
ist ja auch klar deswegen hatte hier
einen letztens gefunden guck mal hier
haben wir zum beispiel ein ja der ist
von 2015 was in ordnung ist hat 43.000
kilometer kostet 25.900 euro du jetzt
mal als beispiel klar der wird
wahrscheinlich wenn ich mein projekt
gefällt ich hab schon verkauft sein dann
gibt es neun aber mir ist auch extrem
wichtig das ist mein auto ist dass ich
also ein bisschen dran rum basteln
lassen kann dass ich den verlieren
lassen kann usw das wollte ich schon
immer mal machen ich möchte nämlich ein
neongrün mustang vielleicht ändert sich
die farbe auch nochmal aber hier mal ein
bild es ist einfach zu wild oder schwarz
sind neongrün juli also das ist das ziel
für diese videoreihe superwichtig ein
ziel zu haben glaubt damit es auch für
die zuschauer cool ist schreibt eure
meinung dazu gern meine kommentare ich
habe auch wirklich lange überlegt ob ich
mich ernsthaft jetzt hinsetzen kann man
sagen kann dass viele sind 30.000 euro
und ich hab mir auch vorgenommen das
ganze in vier monaten zu schaffen was
nicht glaube ich schon schaffen kann ich
erkläre euch gleich wie man ist ja so
wild also ich hätte dann einfach wieder
mein als autos war mein erstes auto und
ich habe das auto mehr gefeiert da jetzt
habe ich auch ein auto was super
neuestes das ist ein leasing wagen
gehört nicht mir und ich bin die ganze
immer wenn ich ein muster jähriger ist
ich vieles einfach so türlich v8 es war
ihr wisst dass ich bin mal gespannt was
ich habe ja auch glaube ich noch ein
paar mustang fancy als zuschauer was ihr
dazu sagt allein wenn ich schon denken
kriechen happy gefühl und dafür ist es
auch einfach zum youtube videos zu
machen und klar wenn ich sowas jetzt
meiner mama erzählen würde würd sagen
ist doch bekloppt was auch ein auto aber
dann nicht mehr so was den kopf gesetzt
habe ich das auch durchziehen und ich
hoffe es also leute ich hatte von diesem
recht projekten noch 1100 euro das habe
ich glaube ich bereits eingeblendet los
dann habe ich jetzt noch mal 1000 euro
aus meiner eigenen tasche investiert
davon noch mal so eine neue saturn
wundertüte gekauft ich weiß ich habe mir
schon so oft gemacht aber es ist einfach
ein extrem guter start ich muss an
dieser stelle auch sagen schaut aus an
dave der macht das ja auch so ähnlich
also trade up mäßig das wollte ich auf
jeden fall mal erwähnt klar er macht das
glaube ich zu einer rolex ich glaube er
ist man schon ziemlich weit trägt das
gern mal ab und bei mir ist es jetzt ein
auto und schwarz aber auch anders machen
als dave ich glaube nämlich wenn ich
nicht irgendwie ein bisschen auch die
youtube reichweite spielen lasse ist es
quasi unmöglich es geht nicht also da
brauchst du ewig und ich hoffe ihr nehmt
mir das nicht übel auf dem weg den ich
mache aber sonst ist es einfach
umsetzbar da muss man auch realistisch
sein also starten wir quasi mit ungefähr
2100 euro 1000 euro habe ich für diese
saturn wundertüte bezahlt also 2000 euro
warenwert mindestens drin sein das neue
saturn da habe ich noch nie bestellt und
was ich auch sagen muss das ganze hat
absolut nichts mit meinem online shop zu
tun also die sachen werden da nicht
verkauft also das ist eine andere
geschichte und den online shop lassen
wir außen vor ich wäre das alles
irgendwie so versuchen das geld was ihr
damit verdienen kommt dann alles auf das
konto floss das geld was sich mit diesen
ganzen youtube videos die sich auf
dieses geld experiment beziehen werde
ich auch auf das konto legen das werde
ich euch auch genau zeigen wie viel ich
dann mit einem video verliert was man ja
machen darf habe ich sonst noch nie
gemacht aber ich werde es machen dann
werde ich natürlich schauen von folge zu
folge wie ich das vermehren kann was
kann nicht kaufen was soll ich besser
nicht kaufen wo kann ich das geld
vielleicht auch mal ein investiert klar
das kann man auch mal überlegen und wenn
sich dann noch ein cooler
kooperationspartner für diese video
reihe findet werde ich vielleicht auch
mal ein place machen was ich dann
ebenfalls damit rein rechnerisch kann
man jetzt so und so sehen aber wie
gesagt es ist einfach halt wer und
unmöglich sich aber gern von anderen
seite ich meinen dann könnt ihr mal
realistisch sehen wie schnell es geht
als youtuber geld zu verdienen oder
vielleicht eben auch nicht ich glaube
das ist ein cooler ein weg und wie
gesagt schreibt super gerne eure
meinungen kommentare wenn ihr sagt dass
absolut bullshit nehme ich das auch an
aber warte erstmal ab weil ich denke
schon dass es interessant wird dann bin
ich mal gespannt wie lange es dauert und
wir machen jetzt erst mal das paket auf
weil das ist der staat zum ganzen jetzt
leute hier was haben wir denn hier das
paket ist viel zu groß und kann mich ja
gar nicht sehen ich weiß heute hier
sieht ein bisschen chaotisch zum
hintergrund nehme es mir nicht übel so
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ich habe das
lange nicht gemacht werden so ein teures
paket das ding gibt hier auf jeden fall
zwölf kilo ich hoffe mal für die ich
meine das war saturn krefeld dass sie
mir da gute sachen eingepackt haben ohne
kamera
warten wir mal hier mit glaubt das sind
gläser oder so was soll das denn die
sind ja dreck gehe ich mal da ist viel
dreck drin ganz ehrlich also auf den
ersten blick wirkt das hier so als wären
ein paar sachen davon auf jeden fall
nicht neu was super schade ist und sehr
schlecht für mein status geld
experimentes bzw der mustang ist
versuchen gerade auch traurig na ja ich
will doch gar nicht zu negativ denken
weil wir machen erstmal weiter hier
haben wir habe ich noch nie gesehen
strong bond ja ich hab bei saturn
bestellt und nicht bei teddy oder so
okay dann haben wir hier ein sehr
schweres paket wird ist das denn krieg
maker ultimate smart cutting machine ach
so das hier ist eine schneidemaschine
ich zeig dir euch mal die ist echt
schwer könntest ja sehen vielleicht
kennt ihr die ja die wird wahrscheinlich
schon so baue ich muss hier erstmal
abstellen also die wir denke ich schon
nicht ganz günstig sein dann haben wir
hier eine okay das ist schon mal sehr
gut wir haben hier eine sony alpha
6100 eine geile kamera wie glaube ich
schon 1200 euro kostet und die sieht
auch ungeöffnet aus geil alter das ist
schon mal ein eis das heißt ich muss nur
die hier verkaufen und habe schon
gewinnen gemacht das kriegen wir denke
ich hin und die sony alpha 6100 ist auch
super beliebt wie wird safe schnell weg
hin dann haben wir hier ein krieg ot si
press mini bat night i was ist das denn
all das hat ein bügeleisen stempel easy
press sieht aus wie eine mini presse um
irgendwas zu pressen und zu guter letzt
dann war's das auch schon ein samsung
galaxy tab s6 das ist jetzt auch nicht
mehr warten dass sechs okay da ist dann
pennen dabei das wird sicherlich auf 2
300 euro kosten oder das war es leider
schon auf jeden fall ein superschnelles
saturn unboxing okay jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt da müssten doch eigentlich die
original preise bei stehen war zumindest
sonst immer so also ihr habt ja immer
die preise eingewendet gesehen ich
checke mal kurz für mich selber ab was
die kamera kostet und was das tablet
kostet ich bin aber alsdorf zufrieden
also ich glaube das kann ganz gut werden
okay leute schon mal gute nachrichten
insgesamt kommen wir auf knapp 2000 auch
ich glaub nicht ganz sonst hier nochmal
der richtige gesamtbetrag an was alles
neu kostet klar das werde ich nicht
dafür bekommen aber ich habe viel
erfahrung und ich weiß dass die sache
ganz gut sind und auf jeden fall schnell
weggehen werden und wenn ich alles
verkauft haben ist das auf jeden fall
ein sehr sehr guter start mit dem ich
zufrieden sein kann ich denke 600 euro
gewinnen ist drin leute was geht wir
haben mittlerweile schon sonntag das
video soll auch heute online kommen und
ich wollte noch mal ein kurzes update
geben ich wollte eigentlich noch in
dieses video anhängen wie ich jetzt
versuche sache weiter zu verkaufen ich
wollte auch mal an- und verkauf testen
klar das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so
viel bringen aber man kann es ja mal
versuchen wir haben ja auf jeden fall in
der nähe so ein paar läden einen kenne
ich auch deswegen check war das mal ab
und mal gucken ob es das lohnen kann ich
kann sagen die kamera die nicht 1200
euro kostet sondern mittlerweile auch
1000 euro bei saturn oder 999 wir haben
also die sony alpha 6100 habe ich schon
verkauft also noch nicht aber ich habe
einen käufer der hat 120 euro gespart
also ich habe sie jetzt für 880 verkauf
das ja voll ok das ist auf jeden fall
schon mal sehr nice wir müssen jetzt
noch das restliche zeug los werden und
dann denke ich schon dass ich so circa
600 euro an der sache verdienen werde
was ein guter start ist ihr könnt auch
super gerne in die kommentare schreiben
was ich noch so anstellen soll mit dem
geld und was im nächsten jahr dann auch
interessant dass ich werde halt die
einnahmen von diesem video auf oben
drauf rechnen sonst ist es halt nahezu
unmöglich und da wird halt viel viel
viel zu lange dauern denke ich mal gut
vielleicht entwickelt sich ja auch eine
richtung wo ich das dann nicht machen
muss aber ich glaube nicht also man
einfach realistisch sein habe ich ja
schon auf gesagt leute ich bedanke mich
fürs zuschauen abonniert den kanal wenn
ihr weitere parks von diesem experiment
sehen wollt und mal schauen wie lange es
dauert bis ich mein mustern bedarf